l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire du projet loi relatif à
l'accélération des procédures liées à la
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaires à proximité de sites
nucléaires existant ou au fonctionnement
des installations existantes la parole
est à Madame Maud Braison rapporteur de
la commission mixte paritaire
c'est pour 5 minutes tout à fait
bien merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues le
chemin législatif du projet de loi pour
l'accélération du nucléaire arrive à son
terme nous votons aujourd'hui les
conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire qui a trouvé un accord sur ce
projet entre l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat c'est une triple bonne nouvelle
d'abord une bonne nouvelle pour le
climat puisque le nucléaire pilotable
c'est l'assurance d'un mix électrique
décarbonée et un complément et un
complément essentiel aux énergies
renouvelables le tout pour sortir des
énergies fossiles bonne nouvelle ensuite
pour les consommateurs particuliers et
entreprises puisque ces futurs réacteurs
contribueront à fournir une énergie à
bas coût produite en France bonne
nouvelle enfin pour notre souveraineté
énergétique la guerre en Ukraine nous
l'a très clairement rappelé il n'y a pas
de souveraineté industrielle sans
souveraineté énergétique chère remercier
tous ceux qui ont contribué à faire
aboutir ce texte
mon collègue rapporteur du Sénat Daniel
grimillier avec lequel nous avons
longuement travaillé pour parvenir à
trouver un accord entre nos deux
chambres merci également à Guillaume
kasbariian le président de la commission
des affaires économiques pour son
implication tout au long de
l'instruction et merci enfin à tous les
parlementaires qui au contribué au débat
et à enrichir ce texte peu importe le
groupe dans lequel vous êtes alors
qu'elle approche lors du vote la
question que chacun d'entre nous doit se
poser et au fond très simple quel modèle
énergétique voulons-nous pour l'avenir
voulons-nous le modèle et l'ambition
porté par le général de Gaulle Georges
Pompidou puis Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
héritage historique synonyme
d'indépendance de décarbonation et de
maîtrise des prix ou à l'inverse
voulons-nous la fuite en avant de sortir
du nucléaire à l'amande allemande pour
le plus grand plaisir des gaziers des
puissances étrangères avec des mines de
charbon à ciel ouvertes pour moi la
réponse est assez simple
chers collègues ce texte aura tenu
toutes ses promesses tant sur le plan
technique que sur le plan programmatique
permettant d'avancer un peu plus vers
les objectifs fixés par le Président de
la République lors de son discours de
Belfort côté programmatique je pense
évidemment à la suppression du plafond
des 50 % et à la suppression de la
limite de puissance installée décision
prise par François Hollande pour
affaiblir la filière sur la base de
considérations idéologique en cohérence
et à la demande du Sénat la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
pourra donc faire l'objet d'une révision
simplifiée sur ce point sur les
dispositions techniques du texte celle
qui permettent d'accélérer nous
conservons la définition consolidée
introduite par l'Assemblée nationale de
la réalisation d'un réacteur
électronucléaire qui inclut les travaux
préparatoires et les ouvrages de
raccordement sur chacun des articles du
titre premier nous avons globalement
conservé la version de l'Assemblée
nationale veillant à ne pas complexifier
et alourdir les processus avec nos
homologues sénateurs nous avons
également beaucoup échanger et
travailler sur la question de
l'artificialisation engendrée par la
construction d'un réacteur afin que
celui-ci ne pèse pas sur le seul
territoire où il est situé cet
artificialisation sera donc exclu du
décompte qui est effectué à l'échelle
locale et régionale tout en renvoyant à
une loi future prise avant le 1er
janvier 2024 le soin de fixer les
modalités précises de décompte des
grands projets à l'échelle nationale
j'en viens au sujet de la réforme de la
SN et l'IRSN sans revenir sur les
questions de méthode dont nous avons
déjà beaucoup parlé ici j'ai veillé
conformément au vote qui ont eu lieu
dans cette émission à retirer du texte
toutes mention directe ou indirecte à ce
projet de rapprochement cela vaut pour
les rapports qui mentionnaient des
études à ce sujet comme cela vaut pour
l'amendement de mon collègue Benjamin
sainte-huile dont j'ai parfaitement
compris l'objectif mais qui venait
déséquilibré le système actuel puisqu'il
mettait sur un même plan l'ASN et l'IRSN
nous avons cependant introduit la
faculté pour la SN de recruter plus
facilement du personnel c'est légitime
l'Autorité de sûreté va faire face à une
charge de travaux conséquente avec la
relance du nucléaire tant sur le grand
carénage que sur le renouvellement du
parc historique nous devons lui donner
les moyens nécessaires pour remplir
cette mission garante de la sûreté des
installations nucléaires françaises et
c'est le toujours dans une logique de
maintenir l'excellence de notre sûreté
nucléaire enfin l'article 13 à l'article
13 pardon nous avons maintenu le
renforcement des peines de prison et des
amendes en cas d'intrusion sur un site
nucléaire ainsi que la possibilité
donnée au juge d'interdire l'ensemble
des aides publiques accordées notamment
par l'État ou par des collectivités à
des associations qui s'introduirait
illégalement et dans certains cas sur
des sites nucléaires
je remercie encore une dernière fois
l'ensemble de mes collègues qu'on
participait à ces débats on n'a pas
toujours été d'accord sur la question du
nucléaire on a eu des échanges qui
étaient riches qui étaient parfois vif
je pense que ça fait aussi partie de la
vie de cette Assemblée nationale en
première lecture on a eu un vote à une
très large majorité j'espère que ce sera
le cas encore une fois ici pour le
climat pour la souveraineté pour les
emplois pour les femmes et les hommes
qui font cette filière à qui nous devons
beaucoup ils sont le visage de cette
industrie et de cet excellence à la
française et c'est aussi pour eux que
nous devons frotter ce texte aujourd'hui
je vous remercie je vous remercie la
parole est à Madame Agnès panier rue
naché ministre de la transition
énergétique
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente messieurs les
présidents de commissions mesdames les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés vous avez une nouvelle fois la
responsabilité de vous prononcer sur un
texte majeur pour bâtir l'indépendance
énergétique de notre pays la
responsabilité de vous prononcer sur un
texte qui contribuera au défi du siècle
libérer notre pays de sa dépendance aux
énergies fossiles la responsabilité en
fin de vous prononcer sur un texte qui
permettra à notre pays de produire une
énergie abondante compétitive et
décarbonée l'objectif du gouvernement
est clair atteindre la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 cela suppose de
réduire drastiquement notre consommation
de pétrole et de gaz fossiles qui pèsent
encore pour deux tiers de notre
consommation d'énergie finale pour
réunir pour réussir l'immense défi de
long terme de se libérer des énergies
fossiles nous devons construire un
consensus politique qui transcende les
étiquettes partisanes c'est l'un des
principaux apprentissages du rapport de
la commission d'enquête men par vos deux
collègues Raphaël chelenberger Antoine
Armand notre politique énergétique ne
peut pas se permettre de subir à nouveau
les atermoiements et les décisions
erratiques qui ne se fonde ni sur la
science ni sur la raison mais sur des
accords électoralistes de circonstances
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
suis convaincu que nous posons depuis
quelques mois les fondations d'impact de
renouveau énergétique impact pour faire
face à l'urgence climatique il y a
l'urgence énergétique impact qui repose
sur des discussions nourries et
approfondi entre le gouvernement et le
Parlement mais également avec les élus
locaux les associations
environnementales les entreprises et
plus largement l'ensemble des Français
je vais d'ailleurs en profiter pour
saluer les milliers de nos concitoyens
qui ont contribué à la grande
concertation sur le futur mix
énergétique de notre pays je me réjouis
qu'il s'empare de ces sujets certes
complexes mais absolument déterminant
pour l'avenir
notre énergie est aujourd'hui au coeur
du débat public et au coeur de nombreux
travaux parlementaires que vous avez
initié il est donc essentiel que nous y
travaillons ensemble car comme j'ai
souvent l'occasion eu de le dire il n'y
aura pas d'indépendance politique sans
maîtrise énergétique après l'adoption
des textes sur la sécurisation nous
approvisionnements énergétiques et sur
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable je souhaite avec
le projet de loi d'accélération des
procédures administratives nucléaires
pour suivre la relance de notre filière
nucléaire je me réjouis de l'accord
trouvé en commission mixte paritaire au
terme d'un dialogue très dense je tiens
particulièrement à remercier le
président Guillaume kasbariian la
rapporteur Maud Brejon les députés
Louise Morel et Antoine Armand ainsi que
tous les autres membres de la commission
pour leur investissement qui a permis ce
succès et je veux saluer tous les
travaux préparatoires à la commission
mixte paritaire parce que je sais que le
dialogue a été très intense entre les
rapporteurs c'est un signal fort envoyé
à notre filière pour qu'elle se mobilise
en vue du lancement du programme de
construction de 6 EPR 2 et la mise à
l'étude de 8 supplémentaires et je le
dis nous ne nous interdirons pas d'aller
plus loin en fonction de la réalité nos
capacités industrielles vous le savez
l'enjeu des compétences est au cœur de
la transition énergétique cela est
particulièrement vrai pour la filière
nucléaire c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai demandé à la filière de dresser un
état des lieux précis des besoins en
compétences pour réussir la relance les
résultats de l'étude qui nous ont
réalisés sont limpides 100 000 100000
voilà le nombre d'emplois que la filière
estime nécessaire de recruter au cours
de la prochaine décennie des soudeurs
des chaudronniers des tuyauteurs ou
encore des ingénieurs autant
d'opportunités au cœur des territoires
pour les jeunes ou les travailleurs en
reconversion de prendre part au plus
grand projet industriels de notre pays
depuis les années 70 ce sont eux les
visages de la génération France nation
verte
dans le prolongement de ce travail je
ferai également le point avec
l'Université des métiers du nucléaire
début juin sur la stratégie de formation
qu'elle mettra en oeuvre pour répondre à
ses besoins de compétences ce projet de
loi sur le nucléaire matérialise plus
profondément le soutien du gouvernement
et du Parlement et une politique
énergétique ambitieuse et crédible je me
félicite à ce titre de notre refus tout
au long de l'examen de la loi d'opposer
nucléaire et énergies renouvelables car
notre urgence je le répète et de sortir
des énergies fossiles et nous aurons
autant besoin du nucléaire que des
énergies renouvelables pour y parvenir
alors et je vous le dis avec conviction
oui accélérer le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables c'est être
écologiste oui relancer notre filière
nucléaire c'est être écologiste car
comment se dire écologiste en préférant
les énergies fossiles aux énergies des
carbonées
avec ce projet de loi nos accélérons
également le renforcement de l'ensemble
de notre filière permise notamment par
la montée au capital de DF les
investissements pour moderniser notre
outil de production comme un Framatome
au Creusot dans la continuité du plan
France relance et avec le plan France
2030 pour investir et inventer les
nouvelles technologies nucléaires
cette ambition je la porte même au-delà
de nos frontières je m'emploie en effet
depuis plusieurs mois à réunir nos
partenaires européens au sein d'une
alliance du nucléaire civile nous sommes
désormais 15 États membres à travailler
aux côtés de la Commission européenne
pour que l'énergie nucléaire trouve sa
place dans le mix énergétique européen
auquel s'ajoute le Royaume-Uni j'ai
d'ailleurs réuni ce matin même au
ministère de la transition énergétique
mais homologues pour faire le point sur
nos projets de nouveaux investissements
dans le nucléaire c'était également tout
le sens de mon déplacement il y a trois
semaines au côté du président directeur
général d'EDF lucrémont sur le chantier
britannique de l'eprince pour défendre
notre savoir-faire d'excellence à
l'export mesdames et messieurs les
députés votaient définitivement ce texte
c'est permettre à notre pays de réaliser
une grande avancée écologique en
mobilisant tous les leviers de
décarbonation pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est aussi
donner l'opportunité à notre pays de
conjuguer réindustrialisation et
maîtrise énergétique c'est lancé le
chantier du siècle en matière
industrielle et d'emploi la prochaine
loi de programmation énergique climat
dont je vous détaillerai prochainement
la préparation devra être ambitieuse et
réaliste au regard de nos capacités j'en
saurai la garante je nous invite donc à
poursuivre collectivement le travail
initier pour bâtir la souveraineté
énergétique de notre pays je vous
remercie
alors j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde panot
et des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale une motion de
rejet préalable déposée en application
de l'article 91
alinéas 5 du règlement et donc la parole
est à Monsieur Maxime l'aîné
[Applaudissements]
vous n'aimez rien
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur chers collègues je
voudrais commencer par
préciser le cadre de notre réflexion et
dissiper les caricatures dans lesquelles
certains voudraient nous enfermer les
députés elle est finie UPS abondent dans
le sens du GIEC oui l'urgence est de
diminuer drastiquement nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre cela passe
évidemment par la sortie des énergies
fossiles et l'électrification des usages
mais cela nécessite aussi un effort
collectif de sobriété sans précédent des
choix de société qui passent par une
véritable planification démocratique
permettant l'accès de tous à ce bien
commun qui est l'énergie ce sont bien
ces objectifs qui nous conduisent
aujourd'hui à considérer votre texte
comme dangereux un texte qui s'inscrit
dans une temporalité qui entache sa
légitimité tout a été fait dans le
désordre et ce projet de loi se place
dans un contexte juridique spécifique
celui de l'obligation du dépôt de la
première loi de programmation énergie
climat dites lpec avant le 1er juillet
prochain rendez-vous désormais comme
intenable pourtant seul cette loi de
programmation pourrait décider de la
relance ou non du nucléaire impossible
selon la loi en vigueur pour cette
raison nous avions défendu avec tous les
députés de la nupesse un amendement pour
soumettre l'application de ce texte à la
prochaine LPC afin de ne pas emprunter
le contenu c'était sans compter sur la
fourberie du gouvernement qui sachant
qu'une majorité serait difficile à
construire sur le futur mix énergétique
a opté pour deux lois distinctes soit
disant procédural une loi sur les
énergies renouvelables qui confirment
l'absence de planification et votre foi
dans la main visible du marché et une
loi sur le nucléaire qui pulvérise le
plafond de production de cette énergie
tout en permettant une révision
simplifiée de la programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie donc sans attendre
l'adoption d'une prochaine lpec un tour
de force dénoncé par la Commission
nationale du débat public le générale
Macron pourrait ainsi réaliser son
caprice de Belfort et avec l'appui de
madame la ministre qui vient de créer
des groupes de travail sur cette loi de
programmation
en excluant notre groupe au motif qu'il
serait en dehors de l'arc républicain
une posture purement politicienne
puisque ce matin même vous rencontriez
vos homologues d'extrême droite de la
Hongrie Dorban et de l'Italie de Mélanie
pour imposer la relance du nucléaire en
Europe sans compter vos liens avec la
Russie puisqu'environ 40 % de votre
approvisionnement en uranium passe par
les sociétés proches du Kremlin quelle
valeur accordée à votre parole dans ces
conditions quelle confiance avoir quand
vous nous assurez vouloir sortir de la
loi toute référence à la fusion de la
ESN et de l'URSS alors même que vous
avez voulu l'imposer à la hussardes dans
le débat parlementaire nous avons réussi
à nous y opposer durant la séance si la
CMP a confirmé ce choix ce dont nous
nous félicitons elle a écarté la
victoire que nous avions obtenue celle
de graver dans le marbre de la loi la
dualité de notre régime de sûreté qui a
fait ses preuves nous serons donc
extrêmement vigilants pour éviter le
retour de cette fusion que plus rien
interdit
autre recul en CMP la possibilité
offerte de s'extraire du zan il sera
donc demain plus facile pour l'État
d'implanter une centrale que de bâtir
une crèche pour un maire enfin
l'obsession répressive de ce
gouvernement permet dorénavant de couper
les vivres des associations qui
s'introduirait sur des sites nucléaires
pour y déployer des banderoles actes et
côte terroristes dont chacun pourra
apprécier la dangerosité à ce stade du
processus parlementaire nous voulons
dénoncer le climat qui a présidé à nos
débats où l'arc de la droite est
l'argile à tenter de nous faire passer
pour des adeptes du charbon ou des
idéologues de la bougie
cet esprit nous l'avons retrouvé dans
une vidéo de Madame la rapporteur obligé
d'ajouter d'agiter l'épouvantail
allemand pour mieux vanter la relance du
nucléaire français en Allemagne pourtant
entre 2000 et 2022 écoutez vous allez
apprendre des choses la production du
nucléaire a baissé de 135 terwatts celle
du charbon de sang c'est un watt-heure
alors que la production des ENR
augmentait de 216 terawattheure ce n'est
donc pas de charbon qui remplace le
nucléaire chez notre voisin mais bien
les renouvelables qui permettront à
l'Allemagne de sortir des fossiles des
2038 c'est-à-dire bien avant nous vous
avez préféré les débats caricaturaux
pour éviter de répondre à nos questions
pourtant essentiels des questions qui
intéressent aussi nos concitoyens mais
également les salariés de la filière que
je veux saluer ici y compris ces
milliers de sous-traitants qui assurent
80% des opérations de maintenance et
reçoivent 80% des doses d'irradiation
quel sera le coût de votre futur le
programme nucléaire pour combien de
réacteurs les 14 annoncés dans l'article
1er d les 9 supplémentaires envisagés
dans ce même rapport ou seulement les 6
sur lesquels EDF et son PDG sont prêts à
s'engager pour 52 milliards autre
question sans réponse qui paiera EDF ses
clients le contribuable livret A des
startups et autres pipi dans quelles
conditions de sûreté seront prolongés
les centrales vieillissantes et à quel
coup concernant les paris technologiques
combien de milliers d'heures
d'ingénierie sont encore nécessaires
pour mettre au point le PR2 combien de
temps pour que Framatome aboutissent sur
les process de fabrication en série des
cuvées découvertes souhaitez-vous
reproduire à l'infini le fiasco de
Flamanville désormais présenté comme un
prototype un prototype toujours pas en
service après 12 ans de retard et dont
la facture a déjà été multipliée par 6
qui nous dit encore que les différents
problèmes de corrosion et de fissures ne
concerneront pas vos nouvelles centrales
quelle place pour les SMS
vous présenter comme la solution miracle
alors même qu'il ne s'agit que d'un
concept aux États-Unis pays le plus
avancé sur ce terrain sur 50 projets un
seul a été certifié pour être ensuite
abandonné combien devrions-nous encore
importer d'uranium lorsque l'on sait que
six EP R2 en est citeraient en
nécessiterait 1000 tonnes qui viendrait
s'ajouter au 7000 tonnes déjà importés
chaque année que ferons-nous des déchets
puisque le permis de sigeo à burne a été
n'a pas été révisé pour tenir compte de
cette relance qu'allons-nous faire des
200000 tonnes de déchets déjà présents
sur notre sol à lag au lot nous fait
croire que le combustible usé pour un
jour resservir c'est l'équivalent de 130
réacteurs qui est déjà concentré je
rappelle également que derrière l'image
d'une énergie propre les mines d'uranium
à l'étranger dont nous dépendons
entièrement relève parfois du scandale
néocolonial comme dans la mine de Comina
konigère ou sans tasse 20 millions de
tonnes de résidus radioactifs à l'air
libre il reste une autre question sans
commence et pour cause il n'y en a pas
qui peut nous garantir qu'il n'y aura
pas d'accident majeur personne pas même
le président de l'Autorité sur pied
nucléaire qui affirme que dire le
contraire serait irresponsable la
catastrophe de Fukushima nécessité le
déplacement de plus de 150000 personnes
la zone d'exclusion reste de plus de 300
km² soit 3 fois la surface de Paris
comme ignorer ces questions au moment
même où l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique a alerte sur le
risque d'un grave accident nucléaire à
la centrale de zaporigia qui peut nous
garantir une paix éternelle sur le
continent évidemment personne au-delà de
ces multiples questions il y a un
constat simple le nucléaire n'est pas
résilient au changement climatique
engagé le rapport de la Cour des comptes
prévoit ainsi une multiplication par 3
ou 4 des indisponibilités des centrales
pour cause de réchauffement climatique
de son côté l'URSS indique que 20
réacteurs sont exposés au risque
d'inondation que des 2050 Gravelines et
le Blayais pourraient avoir les pieds
dans l'eau dans le même temps le débit
du Rhône pourrait diminuer de 40%. là où
il restera de l'eau pour faire tourner
les réacteurs celle-ci sera bien souvent
trop chaude pour pouvoir accueillir
celle rejetée du fait de ses impacts sur
la biodiversité nous savons donc déjà
que certains réacteurs seront à l'arrêt
quand les autres seront en conflit avec
les autres usages indispensables de
l'eau pour boire et se nourrir pour les
centrales en bord de mer nous regrettons
une prise en compte beaucoup trop faible
du recul attendu du trait de côte alors
qu'appe en lit le dossier du maître
d'ouvrage ne prévoit qu'un maître de
marge dans la conception nous ne sommes
pas les seuls à exiger ces réponses les
conclusions de la commission du débat
public publié en avril indique ainsi que
beaucoup de ces questions essentielles
sont encore à ce jour sans réponse
aucune d'entre elles n'apparaît mineur
mais vous préférez le mépris prenant le
Parlement pour une chambre
d'enregistrement de décision prise
ailleurs notamment dans le Conseil de
politique nucléaire à la main de Vulcain
d'Anthony souhaité qu'il reste à Jupiter
car de mettre des Forges avec quelques
connaissances en soudure nous en
saurions ravis mais nous aurions préféré
pouvoir compter sur le protecteur du
ciel et de la terre décrit dans la
mythologie ainsi nous ne serions
peut-être pas confrontés au Daily
principal porté par ce texte et ses
turifères aucune nouvelle centrale ne
produira le moindre kilowatt avant 2040
un délai incompatible avec l'urgence de
nos objectifs de décarbonation la
nouvelle condamnation de l'État dans
l'affaire du siècle nous rappelle ainsi
que le temps nous est compté tout argent
investi dans un nouveau programme
nucléaire et donc un argent détourné de
la capacité d'investir dans l'air
nouvelle ainsi que dans les adaptations
du réseau et le développement des
flexibilités nécessaires votre volonté
de maintenir le nucléaire comme sur ce
principal de production d'électricité
fait aussi l'impasse sur la nécessité de
remettre en cause nos modèles
consuméristes et productivistes
maintenant l'illusion d'un monde sans
fin au passage vous inventez un septième
scénario ultra nucléarisé que même RTE
n'avait pas osé imaginer dans ses futurs
énergétiques
vous pouvez dès lors engager vous ne
pouvez dès lors engager cette reprise
nucléaire sans réelle consultation
démocratique et sans réponse sérieuse à
nos questions pour toutes ces raisons
nous proposons cette motion de rejet à
défaut nous saisirons le Conseil
constitutionnel
je vous remercie
madame la ministre souhaitez-vous
prendre la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les députés de la France
insoumise en fait
au-delà du jeu des 7 erreurs auxquelles
on aurait pu se livrer par rapport à
tous les mensonges que vous avez
accumulés dans votre présentation la
France sort avant l'Allemagne du charbon
ne serait-ce que cet exemple là puisque
c'est avant 2030 le chat l'Allemagne
c'est 2038 la France est au-dessus de
l'Allemagne en matière d'énergie
renouvelable en 2021 dans la
consommation finale la France n'est pas
dépendante de la Russie en matière
d'approvisionnement en uranium et le
répéter de manière insistante alors que
vous le savez pertinemment interroge sur
vos sources et sur vos motivations et je
pourrais continuer comme ça mais plus
fondamentalement il y a quelque chose
qui me trouble le gouvernement a soumis
trois textes énergétiques à votre
approbation depuis le début du
quinquennat pour bâtir l'indépendance
énergétique de notre pays trois textes
avez-vous voté pour sécuriser nos
approvisionnements
cet hiver
non vous avez voté contre avez-vous voté
pour accélérer la production d'énergie
renouvelable et donnée enfin les leviers
d'action aux élus locaux non non vous
avez voté contre votre relance
historique de notre chimière nucléaire
pour la souveraineté énergétique de
notre pays là encore vous voterez contre
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
France insoumise je vous le dis avec la
plus grande solennité votez contre les
énergies renouvelables contre le
nucléaire contre l'indépendance
énergétique de notre pays c'est voté
contre la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique c'est condamné les jeunes
générations face aux dérèglement
climatique vous en intéressonsables et
vous porterez cette responsabilité
je vous remercie pour la commission
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
Président est-ce que vous souhaitez vous
exprimer sur la sur la motion alors donc
je vous indique que sur le vote de la
motion de rejet est préalable je suis
saisie par le groupe de la France
insoumise d'une demande de scrutin
public qui a annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée
nous avons plusieurs prises de parole
pour les explications de vote la
première madame Julie lernos
madame la ministre l'examen de ce projet
de loi s'est fait sans respecter le cas
démocratique de la future stratégie
énergétique au mépris des impératifs
écologiques et au détriment des
exigences de sûreté vous avez instauré
choisi d'instaurer un grand désordre
énergétique en présentant deux lois
techniques énergies renouvelables et
nucléaire sans cadre ni perspective sans
rien sur l'efficacité ni la sobriété ni
la sortie des énergies fossiles cette
loi sur le nucléaire était réputée
technique et non programmatique et
pourtant à Nanterre aujourd'hui nos
objectifs fixés en 2015 sur le nucléaire
et inscrit votre volonté à travers un
rapport à construire 14 EPR de alors
même que leur ingénierie n'est pas
abouti ce faisant vous déterminer notre
politique énergétique au doigt mouillé
en foulant au pied tous vos engagements
et en bafouant toutes les concertations
pour pouvoir imposer votre relance
nucléaire
plus grave vous avez tenté de nous
imposer sans que jamais cela n'ait été
abordé la destruction de l'IRSN réduire
au silence l'expert de la sûreté dans le
contexte de changement climatique et de
vieillissement des centrales étaient
absolument irresponsables et
heureusement ça notre assemblée vous la
très clairement fait sa voix pour autant
il n'en reste pas moins que les
propositions qui figurent encore dans ce
texte constituent une régression du
droit environnemental et de la
participation du public une atteinte à
la libre administration des
collectivités mais surtout une négation
totale du contexte actuel de la filière
et de la vulnérabilité des centrales
face au changement climatique les
écologistes voteront donc avec cette
force cette notion de rejet nous
refusons de vous laisser faire sauter
tous les garde-fous autour de l'atome et
minimiser ses dangers sous prétexte que
vous êtes hypnotisé et croyez à tort
qu'il est la solution pour résoudre la
crise climatique énergétique croyez-en
les écologistes vous vous égarez madame
les ministres et c'est dangereux pour
notre avenir enir face au réchauffement
climatique je vous remercie la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Sébastien
jumelles
beau présidente ministre moi j'ai pas de
relation
fougueuse avec le mode de production
énergétique
j'essaie d'avoir une relation
pragmatique
si l'urgence climatique et la première
des urgences
et je crois que c'est le cas il nous
faut produire de l'énergie décarbonée
si le renouveau industriel la relance de
l'industrie est une priorité je crois
que c'est le cas il nous faut pour cela
concevoir l'industrie de l'industrie
c'est à dire une énergie pilotable
pour faire tout cela je le dis entre
parenthèses pour que on n'est pas
l'impression de mon consensus avec le
gouvernement il nous faut une maîtrise
publique totale il nous faut un état
stratège il nous faut reprendre la main
sur le marché vous avez des marges de
progression colossale là dessus même si
la loi que nous avons votée à l'occasion
de la niche communiste contre la vie du
gouvernement est un premier pas que nous
apprécions pour lequel nous avons été
remerciés je trouve que cette PPL nous
permet de rattraper 30 ans de
renoncement en matière de structuration
de la filière nucléaire je le dis entre
parenthèses quand on rend hommage aux
hommes et aux femmes qui font vivre la
filière on flingue pas leur statut dans
le même mouvement c'est pourtant ce que
vous avez fait à la faveur de la réforme
des retraites et je trouve que c'est un
sujet pour l'attractivité de la filière
je l'ai développé à l'occasion de
l'argumentaire que nous avons déployé
pour promouvoir la filière nucléaire
tout cela nous conduira donc à voter
contre la motion de rejet parce nous
considérons que ce texte nous donne les
moyens de recouvrer de la souveraineté
industrielle et de la souveraineté en
matière énergétique mais c'est un vote
évidemment exigeant un vote qui
réaffirme la nécessité de reprendre la
main sur le marché lorsqu'il s'agit du
nucléaire comme lorsqu'il s'agit des ENR
parce qu'il n'y aura pas de bifurcation
écologique de transition écologique
possible de souveraineté industrielle
s'il est à ne reprend pas la main voilà
le sens du vote du groupe GDR sur ce
sujet merci la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Benjamin sainte huile
chers collègues s'il vous plaît
est-ce qu'on peut écouter l'orateur dans
le calme s'il vous plaît
madame la Présidente je vais faire court
au titre du groupe liotte nous
souhaitons et nous l'avons dit à
plusieurs reprises avoir un mix
énergétique équilibré et décarbonée le
sens de la motion de rejet préalable est
une position
radicalement anti-nucléaire et ne
correspond absolument pas aux ambitions
que nous ne sommes fixées il y a un
certain nombre de commentaires à
formuler sur la préparation de ce texte
les objectifs et la manière dont les
choses se sont déroulées mais il est
évident pour nous qu'il faut d'abord
rejeter cette motion de rejet pour
pouvoir évoquer ces différents sujets je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Stéphane
travers
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues nous voterons
bien évidemment vous prenez sens contre
cette motion de rejet totalement
caricatural totalement démagogique le
groupe Renaissance a fait de la filière
nucléaire une priorité pour répondre aux
enjeux de décarbonation et garantir
notre indépendance énergétique nous
votre compte car nous devons nous
inscrire dans la trajectoire de la
neutralité carbone qui doit être
atteinte à l'horizon 2050 nous voterons
contre car nous souhaitons construire un
chemin nouveau pour la filière nucléaire
après des années de tergiversation nous
voterons contre car nous devons
accélérer les procédures qui demain avec
la construction de nouveaux réacteurs
permettront l'électrification des usages
et la décarbonation de notre mix
énergétique dans le discours de Belfort
le président de la République a
réaffirmé son ambition à faire de la
France le premier grand pays à sortir
des énergies fossiles c'est un chantier
du siècle pour l'emploi et la
souveraineté nous ne devons plus
aujourd'hui faire fi des enjeux
climatiques et des enjeux de
l'indépendance énergétique après un vote
à une large majorité à l'Assemblée nous
avons trouvé un chemin et un compromis
en commission mixte paritaire qui ouvre
une nouvelle page de l'histoire de la
filière parce qu'à travers ce texte nous
défendons une vision résolue et moderne
de l'énergie nucléaire nous devons voter
l'accord trouver en CMP et rejeter la
motion de la nuque
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Nicolas dragon
merci
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur madame la ministre chers
collègues le groupe rassemblement
national est ravi qu'il soit enfin
question de la relance de la filière
nucléaire dans cette Assemblée nationale
nous revenons de loin en effet cette
majorité qui nous propose ce texte est
la même que celle qui a désarmé le
nucléaire dans notre pays sous la
précédente législature en fermant
d'abord la centrale de Fessenheim et en
voulant réduire la part du nucléaire à
50% du mix énergétique quel exploit
qu'elle revient quand vous êtes enfin
rendu compte de votre aveuglement je
referme cette parenthèse pour dire que
la macronie n'est pas la seule
responsable avec la nupesse nous avons
ici la gauche pluriel reconstituée quel
plaisir de voir des socialistes des
communistes majoritairement favorables
au nucléaire alors qu'ils ont arrêté
super Phénix en 1998 cela pour faire
plaisir à leur allier écolo les mêmes
écolos toujours aussi bornés 25 ans plus
tard et depuis dans leur hystérie
anti-nucléaire par la France insoumise
félicitations à tous vous avez réussi à
détruire une filière nucléaire autrefois
gage de souveraineté et énergétique
national le groupe rassemblement
national considère que ce texte est le
bienvenu mais largement insuffisant dans
le programme Marie Curie Marine Le Pen
portait d'ailleurs un projet ambitieux
de construction de nouveaux réacteurs
EPR et SMS nous sommes ravis que la
majorité rejoigne nos positions sachez
que nous aurons une attitude à
responsable et ambitieuse sur ce projet
de loi nous le voterons parce qu'il doit
garantir l'approvisionnement en
électricité des Français de nos
entreprises et de nos services publics
il doit aussi réaffirmer l'excellence
industrielle française et relancer la
recherche et le développement le groupe
rassemblement national votre votre a
donc contre cette motion de rejet
outrancière 50 ans après le plan Messmer
nous devons retrouver
ce souffle qui a fait la fierté de notre
pays garant de son indépendance en
électricité je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant à madame la
Présidente Mathilde panot
présidente ministre collègue fidèle à
vous-même en matière de retraite ou de
nucléaire vous êtes la République en
marche forcée dans un cas vous ne
consultez ni le peuple ni les syndicats
ni le Parlement dans l'autre vous
accélérez avant même d'obtenir la
sentiment du plus grand nombre autrement
dit la macronie se heurte à chaque
instant au même obstacle la démocratie
ce sera l'atome à marche forcée sans
attendre la stratégie française relative
à l'énergie au climat ni même la fin de
la concertation nationale sur les
nouveaux EPR oui car depuis les dorures
de l'Elysée Emmanuel Macron et Alexis
colère décide seul du mix énergétique de
la France
vous ne pourrez pas dire que vous ne
saviez pas vous ne pourrez pas dire que
vous ne saviez pas que le nucléaire ne
garantit pas notre souveraineté aussi
longtemps que nous nous fournirons en
uranium à l'étranger vous ne pourrez pas
dire que vous ne saviez pas que 26
réacteurs étaient à l'arrêt cet hiver et
Madame la Ministre merci de ne pas nous
faire de leçon car à cause de cela vous
avez eu recours à du gaz de schiste
États-Unis et au charbon vous ne pourrez
pas dire que vous ne saviez pas qu'en 20
départements sont concernés par des
restrictions d'eau contre 8 à la même
période l'année dernière vous ne pourrez
pas dire que vous ne savez pas que le
dérèglement climatique est commencé vous
ne pourrez pas dire que vous ne savez
pas que les centrales sont impossibles à
refroidir faute de ressources en eau
vous ne pourrez pas dire que vous ne
saviez pas que le nucléaire n'est pas
une solution à la baisse des émissions
quand le GIEC nous donne trois ans pour
agir et que le premier réacteur serait
prêt dans 15 ans vous ne pourrez pas
dire que vous ne saviez pas quand notre
pays croule déjà sous les déchets
nucléaires vous ne pourrez pas dire que
vous ne saviez pas que le nucléaire aire
est une énergie coûteuse comparée aux
énergies renouvelables vous ne pourrez
pas dire que vous ne saviez pas que le
nucléaire est une énergie dangereuse
avant tout pour les salariés du
nucléaire et je pense notamment aux
sous-traitants qui reçoivent 80% de la
dose radioactive
avec ce texte vous présentez des
orientations cruciales qui capteront
notre avenir pour des générations merci
pour son domaine comme dans tous les
autres il vous faudra prendre goût à la
démocratie merci la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Raphaël berger
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame le rapporteur cher
collègue
vous avez dit Madame la Ministre votre
propos introductif qu'il s'agissait
désormais de produire une énergie
abondante compétitive décarbonée nous
sommes tous mobilisés à cela j'ajouterai
disponible et c'est peut-être ce qui
tranche avec les textes que vous avez
présenté jusque là c'est que la solution
du nucléaire elle permet la
disponibilité de l'électricité quand on
en a besoin et c'est bien ça qui a été
le problème que nous avons pu rencontrer
cet hiver c'est bien les défis auxquels
nous aurons à faire face ce n'est pas
seulement d'avoir de l'énergie quand on
en a pas besoin c'est d'en avoir tout le
temps quand c'est nécessaire et face à
la nécessité de relancer cette filière
française d'accélérer la construction de
nouveaux moyens de production d'énergie
décarbonée nous voilà opposés la
stratégie politique qui est toujours la
même de la part des écologistes de la
part de l'extrême gauche la peur la peur
la peur la peur parce que sa mobilise
dans les urnes la peur parce que ça
mobilise la peur mais ça n'apporte
jamais de solution ça n'apporte jamais
de solutions concrètes qui permettent de
rebâtir une nation et bien face à la
peur nous préférons vous opposer la
confiance dans la science la confiance
dans le travail le contrôle de la
technique tout ce qui est permis par
l'histoire de la filière nucléaire
l'histoire de la filière nucléaire qui
est une histoire française l'histoire de
la filière nucléaire qui est une fierté
française et derrière cette fierté
française il y a toujours eu le groupe
les républicains et la volonté de doter
notre nation d'un outil d'indépendance
d'un outil de souveraineté qui nous
permet de nous projeter dans un siècle
qui est celui du défi de la lutte contre
le changement climatique défi pour
lequel nous aurons besoin
d'infrastructures nombreuses qu'il
s'agisse de produire de l'énergie de
stocker de l'eau ou tout simplement de
répondre à l'ensemble des besoins de nos
concitoyens nous aurons besoin
d'infrastructures et souvent nous nous
retrouverons face à un groupe politique
à gauche qui s'oppose à ce que les
hommes puissent vivre digne
je vous remercie
et nous avons le dernier orateur est-ce
que est-ce qu'il est possible mes chers
collègues il y a un brouhaha s'il vous
plaît
s'il vous plaît chers collègues
je vous remercie de voilà qu'on puisse
quand même entendre le dernier orateur
je vous remercie
vous avez la parole monsieur Miliane
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission cher
collègue mes chers amis de la France
insoumise je vais pas relever ici tous
les mensonges que vous avez préféré dans
votre motion de rejet car je crois que
s'il existait un délit de mensonges vous
seriez souvent condamné
à tel point vous montez sur le sujet par
vision dogmatique je suis désolé je vais
vous apprendre une vérité que vous
connaissez parfaitement oui aux énergies
renouvelables mais pas que pour une
raison simple c'est qu'elles ne sont pas
pilotables si votre modèle c'est
l'Allemagne je vais vous livrer les
émissions de CO2 par kilowattheure
produit aujourd'hui à 15h la France 27 g
de CO2 par kilowattheure avec l'énergie
décarbonée du nucléaire l'Allemagne 336
g de CO2 par kWh produit si c'est votre
modèle pour supprimer les gaz à effet de
serre et pour combattre le réchauffement
climatique vous savez quoi le Mouvement
Démocrate n'en veut pas c'est clair
comme ça donc arrêtez de raconter
arrêter de raconter des mensonges à tout
le monde vous mentez tout le temps quand
au déchets nucléaires vous jouez sur la
peur nous avons des milliers d'années
devant nous pour trouver la solution
bien sûr qu'on va commencer à la faire
oui monsieur Boyard du haut de vos 21
ans vous qui savez tout
calmez-vous ça va bien se passer aussi
donc nous rejeterons avec force avec
force cette notion de Roger car nous
voulons un mix énergétique efficace pour
lutter contre les réchauffements
climatiques et pas des idées non
pilotables que vous prenez à longueur de
journée
alors je vous remercie je vais donc
mettre au voile la motion de rejet
préalable je vous prie de bien vouloir
regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
donc votant 355 exprimé 350 majorités
166 pour 60 contre 290 l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas adopté
alors merci pour ce qui quitte
l'hémicycle de le faire dans le calme
s'il vous plaît nous entamons la
discussion générale
et la parole est à Madame Marie-Noëlle
Baptiste
vous avez la parole chers collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues soyons honnêtes la réunion de
la commission mixte paritaire de la
semaine dernière n'est pas de nature à
lever les réserves que nous avons pu
exprimer tout au long de l'examen de ce
texte
ce texte ne répond pas à nos attentes
depuis le début nous ne cessons de
répéter qu'il aurait été évidemment plus
logique plus pertinent que le débat sur
le bien-fondé d'un nouveau programme de
réacteur nucléaire soit traité dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation énergie
et climats prévus à l'été la
programmation doit effectivement se
faire dans une loi de programmation et
pas dans une loi dite technique ça
paraît tout à fait logique à cet égard
nous regrettons vivement l'inscription
d'objectifs programmatique et somme très
inquiets du dispositif réintroduit en
CMP permettant une actualisation de la
PPE par une révision simplifiée dans un
délai d'un an à compter de la
promulgation de la loi
comment également justifier le fait de
transformer l'objectif de réduction à
50% de la part de l'énergie nucléaire
dans le mix électrique français d'ici à
2035 en un plancher alors même que le
scénario RTE le plus nucléarisé ne
franchit pas ce seuil nous sommes
également très dubitatifs des objectifs
énergétiques afférents à l'effort de
recherche et d'innovation ainsi qu'à
l'hydrogène nucléaire tout comme la
précision sur l'objectif de
décarbonation qui devrait passer par la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires et de SMS enfin les
références à la construction de 14
réacteurs aux articles premiers D et
premiers n'ont pas leur place dans ce
texte ces dispositions sont de nature à
être débattues nous le redisons dans le
cadre d'une future loi de programmation
énergique climat et nulle part ailleurs
vous abîmez également la concertation et
la transparence en supprimant le
processus de demande et d'octroi de
l'autorisation d'exploitation d'un
réacteur électronucléaire pourtant
indispensable pour l'acceptabilité des
populations à de tels projets
au moment d'envisager la relance du
nucléaire dans le pays la question est
de savoir s'il n'est pas de savoir s'il
faut gagner 18 mois dans les procédures
administratives alors même que la
construction d'un tel ouvrage durant en
moyenne 15 ans mais plutôt de
s'interroger sur la capacité et les
moyens à déployer pour relever un tel
défi industriel la France n'a pas mené
de programme de construction depuis de
plusieurs réacteurs depuis plus de 20
ans ce constat est synonyme d'une
véritable perte de compétences
industrielle que tout le monde reconnaît
et qu'il faut reconquérir le vin avril
dernier le groupement des industriels
français de l'énergie nucléaire a rendu
son rapport sur les besoins en main
d'oeuvre de la filière les recrutements
concerneraient 100 000 personnes sur
l'ensemble de la période allant de 2023
à 2033 pour les emplois directs et
indirects la filière s'attend à voir le
volume de travail nécessaire croître de
25% sur les 10 prochaines années dans
une vingtaine de segments d'activités
opération personnel la chaudronnerie
verrait ses recrutements augmenter de
140% sur 10 ans et encore plus le génie
civils alors que nous faisons déjà appel
à des soudeurs américains pour les
problèmes de corrosion sous contrainte
les questions qu'il faut donc se poser
sont multiples comment avoir
suffisamment de main d'oeuvre pour
construire de nouveaux réacteurs comme
vous le souhaitez et assurer leur
maintenance dans des conditions de
sécurité optimale comment préparer les
formations professionnelles et organiser
le recrutement quel mode de financement
à déployé et enfin et surtout
serons-nous en capacité de faire tout en
même temps le développement massif des
énergies renouvelables le grand carénage
la construction de nouveaux EPR toutes
ces questions doivent trouver réponse
nous y comptons dans la loi de
programmation énergie climat annoncée
par la première ministre lors de sa
conférence le 26 avril dernier sur le
programme des 100 jours il faut arrêter
de survoler les sujets de manière
technique et poser enfin un l'eau claire
afin d'attendre la neutralité carbone à
l'horizon 2050 pour la future loi de
programmation les attentes sont fortes
la réflexion du groupe socialiste est
apparentée sera essentiellement guidé
par la science l'écologie et les
contraintes techniques humaines posées
par chaque option de mix énergétique
nous revenons d'un séminaire de deux
jours sur les questions énergétiques à
Cherbourg développement massif des ENR
sobriété gestion du cycle de combustige
nucléaire sorti à accélérer des énergies
fossiles maîtrise publique tous ces
sujets doivent être sur la table avant
de conclure nous nous félicitons d'avoir
obtenu lors des débats parlementaires
collectivement une belle victoire avec
la réécriture de l'article prévoyant la
fusion de la SNI RSN il est en effet
essentiel que le modèle français de la
sûreté nucléaire représente sur les
trois piliers soit préservés c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour la démocratie
alimentaire mais nous ne pouvions
accepter qu'un tel projet arrive par
voie d'amendement sans études d'impact
et encore moins sur un sujet aussi
sensible que celui de la sûreté
au final pour ne fermer aucune option et
ainsi conserver toutes les marges de
manœuvre nécessaire à l'élaboration de
la prochaine loi le groupe socialiste
s'abiendra sur ce texte je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Xavier Albertini
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur mes chers collègues
des heures durant en commission ou en
hémicycle nous avons siéger débattus
trouver des compromis autour de ce
projet de Loire relatif à l'accélération
du nucléaire au terme d'un texte et de
leur adoption successifs au Sénat puis à
l'Assemblée nationale seulement 33
articles divergés la commission mixte
paritaire réunit le 4 mai dernier après
un travail efficace et parvenu à la
rédaction d'un texte équilibré et je
tiens à celui état d'esprit qui nous a
animé texte au combien essentiel car il
constitue l'une des pierres angulaires
de l'évolution de la stratégie
énergétique pour la France le cap fixé
par le président de la République était
clair celui du législateur les tout
autant notre pays la France peut-être la
première grande nation à sortir des
énergies fossiles et pour cela il nous
faut nous en donner les moyens
cette stratégie repose d'une part sur un
important effort de sobriété énergétique
le plan mise en oeuvre depuis cet
automne compris et suivi par nos
entreprises Coop par nos concitoyens a
permis de réduire de plus de 10% la
consommation énergétique cet effort
constitue la première marge notre
objectif de réduction de 40 % de notre
consommation d'énergie l'horizon 2050
cette stratégie repose également et
d'autre part sur l'impérius nécessité de
réduire drastiquement les énergies
fossiles celles-ci représentant encore
en 2023 puis les deux plus des deux
tiers de l'énergie consommée ce sont
donc des énergies barquées bas carbone
qui ont vocation à les remplacer le
nucléaire qui s'inscrit dans l'histoire
de notre pays et de nos politiques
énergétiques répond à ce défi de
décarbonation il est aussi la nommé
meilleur atouts pour notre souveraineté
de manière volontariste ce projet de loi
poursuit cette démarche il intègre des
mesures indispensables il réunit des
conditions juridiques financières et
d'organisation nécessaires à la relance
d'une politique française ambitieuse en
matière du nucléaire civile il programme
6 nouveaux E à deux il autorise l'étude
de la construction de 8 paires 2
additionnels ce projet de loi soit
également très clairement le nucléaire
comme principal énergie dans le mix
énergétique français le projet la
prochaine PPE permettra de supprimer le
plafond de 50 % du nucléaire dans la
répartition il vise aussi à simplifier
les démarches administratives relatives
au projet nucléaires portés à proximité
immédiate ou concernant directement des
centrales existantes les dispositions
que nous avons examinées votées
permettront concrètement de pouvoir
gagner plus de deux années dans la
construction d'un nouveau de réacteurs
c'est un gain de temps considérable à
l'occasion de ce débat sur
l'installation de nouvelles centrales
nos collègues sénateurs ont tenté
d'intégrer une réforme du Zéro
artificiel sur nette sous l'angle de
l'aménagement du territoire le zan est
un sujet qui nous préoccupe en tant que
tel et c'est pour cela que la CMP a
conclu dans un consensus que je salue
que ce texte n'était pas le véhicule
législatif opportun
il a donc été convenu de ne pas intégrer
ce point au présentex et le gouvernement
accepté pour sa part d'ouvrir de
prochaines prochainement un débat dédié
le groupe horizon y apparenté tient
salué donc l'équilibre de ce texte
auquel il a pris toute sa part comme un
premier complément nécessaire la loi sur
les énergies de regroupable votez le 11
janvier dernier ce pack législatif
permet de mobiliser l'ensemble des
différentes sources d'énergie backgamod
afin d'atteindre l'objectif de
neutralité que nous sommes
collectivement fixés c'est pour ça que
le groupe horizon apparenté votera ce
texte je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Julie lhermus
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la bataille contre
le réchauffement climatique devrait être
le sujet sur lequel nous devrions être
unis donner accès à une énergie
abordable à tous devraient là encore
être une priorité pourtant sur ce sujet
comme tant d'autres faute d'idées mais
surtout faute d'action le gouvernement a
délibérément choisi une nouvelle fois de
mentir depuis plusieurs semaines nous
assistons à un matraquage effréné pour
faire oublier à la population les
dangers du nucléaire et c'est déboires
technologiques et financiers pour mettre
sous le tapis les déchets radioactifs et
notre dépendance à d'autres nations
comme la Russie pour minimiser les
défaillances graves qui s'enchaînent ces
derniers mois et surtout pour remettre
de dire que si le prix de notre
électricité augmente c'est certes du
fait du conflit en Ukraine mais aussi en
raison de notre dépendance accrue au
nucléaire
le temps ou le nucléaire rimait avec
énergie abondante et abordable et
révolue faire croire le contraire c'est
mentir oui mentir car vous le savez très
bien le nucléaire n'est pas la solution
l'atome ne sauvera pas le climat et ce
n'est pas au climat de servir de
prétexte à votre tentative de sauvetage
de cette filière à la dérive nous
n'avons plus que quelques années pour
faire baisser nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre alors que pour ouvrir un
nouveau réacteur s'il voit le jour il
faut au bas mot 15 à 20 ans à court
terme pas un seul kilowatt d'énergie
fossile ne sera remplacée par le
nucléaire affirmez le contraire c'est
tout simplement mentir il aura fallu 150
heures d'audition de commission
d'enquête pour que le rapporteur
issu de vos rangs tronc de manière
éhonter les conclusions en y inscrivant
des propos chocs qui auraient pu être
écrit avant même d'écouter ne serait-ce
qu'un seul des auditionnés on fait appel
à la nostalgie des anciens et à l'envie
de croire qu'il existerait une solution
magique pour résoudre tous nos mots tout
cela pourrait susciter tant bien que mal
le mythe du nucléaire pour faire croire
que comme dans les années 70 la France
devrait sa grandeur au nombre de ses
réacteurs et que grâce à ces réacteurs
nous pourrons aisément continuer à
produire consommer gaspiller de la même
manière qu'avant mais nous ne sommes
plus dans les années 70 le climat
s'emballe déjà
ces impacts n'appartneront pas les
centrales sans eau elle ne pourront pas
fonctionner inondées elles devrions
interrompt un vrai danger pour notre
sécurité c'était le sens de nos nombreux
amendements que vous avez tous rejeté à
l'image de celui de notre collègue
Monique de Marco qui avait fait adopter
à l'unanimité au Sénat l'interdiction de
construire de nouvelles centrales en
zone submersible comme un déni total de
réalité ce déni de réalité était
particulièrement palpable concernant la
sûreté certes prolongée nos centrales
au-delà du raisonnable valider nouveau
réacteurs au-delà de ce que la filière
dit pouvoir construire prend du temps
car oui l'énergie nucléaire doit aller
faire avec l'exigence de sûreté et c'est
peut-être pour cela que vous avez tenté
par tous les moyens de démanteler l'IRSN
forte heureusement sans succès même si
en donnant la possibilité à la SN de
recruter des contrat actuels vous
fragilisez l'indépendance de notre
sûreté les écologistes ont été forces de
proposition tout au long de l'examen de
ce texte
notre engagement est celui de l'intérêt
général celui pour gagner la bataille du
climat et vous le savez ce n'est pas
avec ce texte abscon qui se noberge
illusion que ceux qui ont désespérément
envie d'y croire qui ne propose aucune
alternative aux énergies fossiles que
nous allons gagner quoi que ce soit
aujourd'hui vous préférez voter avec
ceux qui n'y encore la réalité du
réchauffement climatique et prône le
démantèlement des énergies renouvelables
une loi technique sur le nucléaire qui
ne réglera aucune des problématiques de
la filière et restera un voeu pieux et
désuet face au défi auquel nous faisons
face maintenant madame la ministre allez
vous réellement vous passer dans la
crise énergétique et climatique dans
laquelle nous vivons d'une loi
programmation énergétique est-il
possible en 2023 de ne se donner aucun
objectif en matière de réduction des
missions de gaz à effet de serre alors
certes aujourd'hui vous gagnerez un vote
mais demain pour permettre à notre pays
de construire une majorité autour du
défi majeur qui devrait toutes et tous
nous rassembler c'est vers l'autre côté
de l'hémicycle qu'il faudrait se tourner
car oui une majorité existe bel et bien
pour une programmation énergétique dans
notre assemblée celle de l'efficacité
énergétique de la sobriété du
déploiement massif des ENR pour faire de
ça les piliers de notre trajectoire oui
une majorité avec la gauche et les
écologistes avec celles et ceux qui
travaillent depuis des années
sérieusement à des solutions concrètes
au final pour donner le cadre clair de
nous avons besoin sur un enjeu aussi
essentiel que Vital les solutions
existent les majorités également et pour
cela madame la ministre ne vous en
déplaise merci il faudra se défaire de
ce que vous allez faire adopter
aujourd'hui car aucune trajectoire
crédible sur le climat ne pourra se
faire avec une relance insensée de
l'atome faites votre choix
je vous remercie donc la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Sébastien Jumel
oui monsieur jumelles
vous êtes là c'est l'essentiel
madame la présidente madame le
rapporteur monsieur le président de
commission madame la ministre pardon
chers collègues
responsable
nous devons l'être au moment où la crise
du marché de l'énergie fait exploser les
prix où le réchauffement climatique
existe de nous une réponse concertée
intelligente sur la définition de notre
mix énergétique quel est l'enjeu
assurer notre indépendance énergétique
en organisant notre sortie des énergies
fossiles et en garantissant des prix
stables
par quels moyens en électrifiant les
usages en renforçant la sobriété
énergétique et en s'appuyant notamment
sur ce qui fait la force du modèle
énergétique français depuis le plan
Messmer
la filière nucléaire
avec qui avec EDF comme opérateur public
national qui doit rester intégré comment
en concertant en travaillant avec le
Parlement en respectant les agents EDF
et en travaillant avec les élus et les
citoyens jamais en brute brutalisant je
le dis moi j'ai essayé d'appréhender ce
débat en jetant pas d'anathème à ceux
qui ne pensaient pas comme moi
à ce titre je me fais illicite de la
victoire parlementaire sur voilà ce qui
avait été une mauvaise méthode une
mauvaise idée de fusionner la SN et
l'IRSN nous sommes heureux que voilà la
CMP n'est pas été l'occasion de refaire
venir par la fenêtre ce mauvais projet
pour le reste si nous avons rappelé
notre déception à l'égard de la méthode
choisie par le gouvernement notamment
sur les débats inversés nous considérons
je les dis tout à l'heure qu'il y avait
urgence à relancer cette filière
l'épisode de cet hiver qui a mis en
lumière nos difficultés et compris le
risque de rupture d'approvisionnement
exige de se poser ces questions
essentielles c'est le sujet qui doit
animer cette relance comment accompagner
notre Florent industriel comment
renforcer les moyens des lycées
professionnels comment faire en sorte
que toute la filière soit mobilisée pour
réussir l'enjeu des six EPR annoncés
alors que l'on parle de
réindustrialisation il est maintenant
urgent de prendre soin de celle qu'on
nomme l'industrie de l'industrie clé de
voûte essentiel de la compétitivité de
nos entreprises à une énergie qui doit
rester peu cher et qui doit être au
service de la réduction des gaz à effet
de serre un récent rapport à chiffrer à
100000 le nombre de nouveaux salariés
d'ici 2030 a recruté 100 000 salariés
dont le plus gros besoin sont des
métiers techniques de haut niveau comme
ceux de chef de projet d'ingénieur
d'étude de conception mécanique de
techniciens d'exploitation de
techniciens de maintenance toute notre
énergie doit être à présent concentrée
sur cette objectif après Flamanville qui
a été la démonstration des renoncements
de savoir-faire des abandons de
savoir-faire et même des renoncements de
filières entières il s'agit de faire en
sorte que panli soit le chantier
exemplaire
car si nous sommes responsables au
groupe communiste nous sommes aussi
également extrêmement vigilants
notamment sur la publication du rapport
qui doit éclairer le Parlement sur les
besoins de la filière nucléaire mais
aussi sur les besoins de l'écosystème
qui entoure les filières vous savez ma
préoccupation que la relance de le père
ne doit pas siphonner des industries
présentes sur nos territoires de vie
vigilants aussi sur la prise en charge
locale de cette relance elle implique
des bras supplémentaires elle va
également nécessiter un fort
accompagnement des territoires qui vont
supporter ces efforts logements
formation
infrastructures là aussi si l'on veut
rendre les chantiers exemplaires au plan
social il faudra accompagner des
territoires nous saluons de ce point de
vue le fait que en CMP la question de
l'artificialisation des sols au moins
pour ce qui concerne les besoins strict
de DF étaient intégrés je me rappelle
avoir déposé des amendements dont on
m'avait dit qu'ils étaient
hors sujets heureux de voir que la
raison a fini par l'emporter mais je
dois vous dire que non seulement il
faudra prendre en compte ses besoins
fonciers
non seulement il nous faudra prendre en
compte ses besoins fonciers stricts pour
les réacteurs mais il faudra aussi les
prendre en charge pour les besoins de
logement de service public
d'infrastructures portières et routière
nécessaire au bon déroulement d'un tel
projet bon alors cette loi règle pas
tout le reste elle règle pas la reine
elle règle pas la décorrélation du prix
du gaz dans le mode de construction du
prix d'électricité elle ne réaffirme pas
suffisamment à mon goût le rôle de
détresse stratège de l'État qui protège
de l'État qui se dotent des moyens et
des financements permettant cette
transition et cette construction du
mixte mais le député de panique que je
suis considère que l'étape franchie est
aujourd'hui une étape importante c'est
la raison pour laquelle le groupe
communiste dans sa diversité y compris
respectueux de sa diversité votre ras
majoritairement pour ce texte
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant monsieur Benjamin sainte
huile
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur chers collègues
bon l'urgence climatique n'est plus
contestée ce qui est déjà un progrès il
y a quelques années encore il y avait
des gens suffisamment illuminés pour
considérer que c'était une vue de
l'esprit dans ces conditions le besoin
de mixte des carbonés semble faire
aujourd'hui si pas lui limiter en tout
cas consensus assez largement la sortie
des énergies fossiles et d'un objectif
madame la ministre que vous avez rappelé
à plusieurs reprises et sur lequel nous
nous retrouvons assez aisément dans les
conditions d'urgence qui sont les nôtres
on pourrait considérer que la stratégie
française devrait se construire sur la
base d'un cadre qui pourrait être une
PPE depuis le début de cette législature
nous vous disons s'il faut construire un
mix énergétique alors fixons ensemble
les ambitions fixons un cadre tous
ensemble et ensuite essayons de décliner
des mesures très opérationnelles ce
n'est pas le choix que vous avez fait
vous avez fait l'inverse en choisissant
de partir sur des textes très techniques
dont acte du coup à ce stade à
l'exception des déclarations du
président de la République République à
Belfort pas grand chose sur la question
du mix énergétique et de son équilibre
rien sur la question du marché européen
de l'énergie qu'il faudrait pourtant
réformer rien vraiment en tout cas
d'initiative gouvernementale
gouvernementale pardon sur l'avenir de
DF rien non plus sur le remplacement de
la reine rien non plus sur le
financement des perspectives nucléaires
espérées nous sommes donc là témoin d'un
texte technique qui doit permettre les
accélérations c'est un petit pas mais un
petit pas que nous prenons néanmoins
texte technique oui mais pas seulement
vous avez après avoir la main sur le
cœur considéré que c'était un texte
uniquement technique questionner la
question des plafonds puis des planchers
pour avoir une possibilité de fixer les
choses de manière beaucoup plus libre
bien à travers la CNP nous avons intégré
la dynamique de l'hydrogène qui
correspond là aussi à un premier élément
de programmation surprenant mais
pourquoi pas vous avez fait en sorte à
travers la CMP que la PP la PPE puisse
être modifiée de manière simplifiée ce
qui laisse sous-entendre peut-être que
là encore le Parlement pourrait être
esquivé et nous retrouvons sur la
question du zan qui intéresse tout le
monde et qui devrait justifier un
certain nombre de travaux avant l'été si
nous voulons répondre aux urgences et
aux différents textes qui se succèdent
et qui témoignent de la nécessité de
prendre des décisions communes sur le
sujet vous avez intégré l'idée que ça ne
rentrerait pas dans le décompte bien
heureusement dans tous ces éléments qui
devaient être techniques et ne le sont
pas tout à fait nous avons réussi
collectivement à retrouver le chemin de
la sagesse pour éviter la fusion de
l'IRSN et de la SN non pas que nous ont
nous soyons allergiques par nature ou
par définition initiale mais parce que
la sûreté nucléaire en France a fait ses
preuves ces dernières décennies et que
s'il est
utile de poser la question de savoir
comment elle doit s'organiser dans les
années à venir au regard de la nécessité
de voir l'accélération effective se
mettre en oeuvre alors il faudra prendre
le temps du dialogue de la concertation
et de la construction des perspectives
le groupe liberté indépendant outremer
et territoire en cohérence avec le vote
qu'il avait assumé en première lecture
accompagnera très majoritairement ce
texte puisque nous sommes nous dans
l'idée depuis le départ qu'effectivement
c'est à travers un mixte équilibré et
des carbonées que nous serons en
situation de faire face aux usages et
aux défis de demain de la même manière
que très majoritairement nous avions
voté le texte sur les EnR nous
souhaitons nous appuyer sur le nucléaire
pour permettre notamment ce que les uns
et les autres espèrent et appels à
travers la relance de l'industrie dans
ces conditions le groupe parlementaire
accompagnera ce texte avec intérêt et
bienveillance et oserait-je dire avec
déjà par anticipation un brin de
vigilance sur la future PPE je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Stéphane travers
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues nous arrivons en termes du
processus législatif pour ce texte qui
nous permet d'accélérer les procédures
liés à la construction de nouvelles
installations nucléaires le groupe
Renaissance se réjouit d'une part que ce
texte était adopté à une large majorité
de nos deux assemblées et d'autre part
de l'accord trouvé en commission mixte
paritaire un compromis équilibré
efficace dans un dialogue riche et
toujours construit cela témoigne d'une
volonté partagée de relancer la filière
nucléaire indispensable pour notre
filière énergétique qui a un mix
électrique à la fois pilotable et
décarbonée la large approbation en
deuxième lecture à l'Assemblée illustre
désormais le consensus national qui se
dégage autour de cette énergie depuis
2020 nous avons réduit les procédures
administratives d'installation des sites
industriels nous souhaitons ici aller
plus loin et diviser par deux les délais
d'implantation oui le nucléaire est
indispensable comics énergétique
européen car il permet de compenser
l'intermittence des énergies
renouvelables nous remercions les
sénateurs pour les apports
programmatiques de ce texte et d'être
parvenu avec nous à une commission mixte
paritaire conclusive pour le climat pour
la souveraineté et pour le pouvoir de
l'achat de l'ensemble des Français le
discours de Belfort du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron a réaffirmé
cette ambition de faire de la France le
premier grand pays à sortir des énergies
fossiles avec la construction de six
nouveaux réacteurs le nucléaire énergie
décarbonée est un atout pour la France
nous avons été nombreux à saluer cet
engagement fort d'Emmanuel Macron avec
l'émergence d'une filière modernisée et
qui contribue à l'image des savoir-faire
français notre volonté commune est de
décarboner le mix européen en commençant
par sortir du charbon d'où la nécessité
de construire des centrales qui
produisent l'énergie des carbonée dont
nous avons besoin la Commission a
confirmé la suppression du plancher et
du plafond concernant le nucléaire
concrètement cela signifie que
l'objectif de réduire la part du
nucléaire à 50% est abandonné de même
que le plafond de 63,2 gigawatts de
capacité nucléaire installées ceci était
hérité de la loi de transition
énergétique de 2015
l'artificialisation des sols résultant
de la construction de la réacteur
électronucléaire ne sera pas prise en
compte pour évaluer l'atteinte des
objectifs locaux et régionaux elle sera
comptabilisée au niveau national afin
que le projet n'appate pas uniquement la
commune concertée une loi devra être
adoptée cependant avant le 1er janvier
2024 pour préciser les conditions sujet
qui a suscité de longs débat la fusion à
SN et RSN le projet de rapprochement de
certaines activités de l'IRSN au sein de
la SN a été rejetée par le Parlement et
cela n'a pas été réintroduit en CMP et
les parlementaires ont souhaité
supprimer toute référence à la
réorganisation de la SN et de l'URSS
dans le même temps la CMP a réécrit
l'article 11 qui mentionnait un modèle
de Halle de sûreté expertise et décision
cela doit permettre à la SN de recruter
des agents contractuels selon ses
besoins pour faire face aux besoins
croissants en personnel par ailleurs un
rapport doit analyser les conséquences
d'une fusion il a été confié à l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et techniques la relance
de notre filière est indispensable pour
garantir notre souveraineté énergétique
et c'est pourquoi nous devons moderniser
le parc français et permettre ainsi
l'électrification des usages et des
carbonés notre mix énergétique notre
objectif il est clair bâtir une France
et une Europe plus indépendante car
c'est la clé pour produire de l'énergie
et gagner la bataille de la transition
écologique je sais les désaccords qui
peuvent nous opposer sur certains bancs
je les respecte pour autant ce débat de
fond mérite exigences absence
d'approximation et de ne pas convoquer
comme nous avons pu le voir les peurs
absurdes et la démagogie l'énergie ce
sont des hommes et des femmes engagés
qui la ils exercent des métiers au
service des autres avec trois objectifs
majeurs sur tes sécurités maîtrise des
coûts et préservations du climat le
nucléaire est une chance pour la France
un des grands piliers de notre
indépendance au service de la
réindustrialisation voulue par le
président de la République pour preuve
un milliard d'euros est réservé par la
filière par le président dans le plan
France 2030 pour construire de nouveaux
réacteurs madame la ministre je veux
saluer votre écoute et votre engagement
à la réussite du mix énergétique
permettez-moi également de saluer le
travail et le talent de notre rapporteur
Maud Brejon nous ouvrons aujourd'hui la
nouvelle page de la filière faite de
confiance mais qui garantira aussi sur
nos territoires une exigence de sécurité
et de sûreté et de transparence des
installations que nous devons à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens les
députés du groupe Renaissance voteront
ce texte avec force conviction et
enthousiaste merci de votre attention
je vous remercie d'avoir les maintenant
à Monsieur Jean-Philippe Tanguy
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues au très grand mot les
trop petits remèdes c'est ainsi que je
suis obligé de résumer votre action pour
la relance vitale de notre parc
électronucléaire bien sûr cette loi de
va dans le bon sens c'est à dire le sens
inverse de l'ensemble des décisions
d'Emmanuel Macron après près de 10 ans
ministre plus président de la République
confronté à son total naufrage
idéologique de fin de règne il faut bien
le dire Emmanuel Macron a le don unique
et unique de faire le strict contraire
du macronisme après avoir sombré dans
les abysses de la compétence le Titanic
macroniste laisse échapper quelques
maigres canaux de sauvetage technique
mesurait de bon sens survivant d'une
catastrophe dont vous êtes entièrement
responsable il est évidemment difficile
dans le monde réel de dégoûter à la fois
les jeunes du nucléaire tout en attirant
les talents de fermer à la fois des
centrales nucléaires et d'en ouvrir de
nouvelles de vendre Alstom energy puis
de racheter les turbines de saccager
puis de relancer Astrid la liste n'était
là c'est pas exhaustive de vos
incohérences jamais le groupe
rassemblement national et Marine Le Pen
ne choisiront la politique du pire et
toujours nous soutiendrons les bonnes
mesures pour l'intérêt national aussi
modestes soient-elles nous voterons donc
ce texte en particulier face aux
innombrables mensonges et manipulations
de la nupesse nous avons d'autant plus
de raisons de soutenir ce revirement
qu'il marque avant tout la victoire idé
ologique totale et par chaos du
marinisme le rapport de la commission
parlementaire d'enquête le montre
amplement par le menu le rassemblement
national est la seule force politique à
être parfaitement innocente du saccage
de la filière nucléaire nous sommes
innocents mais surtout courageux
courageux courageux d'avoir été les
seuls à tenir bon pour défendre contre
tous les vents médiatiques et les marées
d'emmagogiques verdâtre des Antilles
nucléaires notre excellence nucléaire
passée présente et surtout notre
excellence à venir quand on en est
réduit comme la macronie à manipuler une
seule phrase de Marine Le Pen en disant
défendant seul la filière nucléaire
après Fukushima alors qu'elle indiquait
avec bon sens qu'il fallait préparer
l'avenir c'est vraiment que vous n'avez
plus honte de rien mais surtout rien à
dire sans honte il n'y a aujourd'hui
qu'un seul plan de relance et
d'innovation pour le nucléaire français
c'est notre plan Marie Curie je salue
néanmoins le travail intègre et
l'expertise incontestable et pour le
moment à contester de la rapporteur mode
région elle nous rend d'ailleurs à bel
hommage en parlant désormais ouvertement
d'un plan Messmer 2 perspective qui
semblait stupide à la macronie en
campagne présidentielle bel hommage bel
hommage aussi aux marinisme madame la
dont la foi votre foie nucléaire semble
sincère dans cette océan d'hypocrisie
macroniste quand j'entends maintenant
que vous avez commencé à mettre aux
oubliettes la maigre ambition d'Emmanuel
Macron de nous construire que 6 ou 14
réacteurs nucléaires d'ici 2050 le gros
rassemblement national l'affirme haut et
fort encore et toujours des nouveaux
réacteurs il en faut 20 avant 2040 et
encore 10 d'ici 2050 la campagne
présidentielle derrière nous se disperse
au fil du mois se disperse au fil du
mois les mensonges et la propagande qui
ont été vos principales armes pour
conserver l’élysées l'industrie lourde a
fait savoir récemment que d'ici 2030 à
elle seule elle avait besoin de 12 EPR
d'ici 2030 de puissance pour pouvoir
réindustrialiser la France 12 réacteurs
supplémentaires pour un seul secteur de
l'économie comment croire Madame la
Ministre que 14 suffiront pour toute la
France le rapport RTE que vous citez
abondamment avait d'ailleurs vendu la
messe de votre hypocrisie bien avant
avec 14 réacteurs nucléaires
supplémentaires il n'est possible selon
eux de rapatrier seulement deux petits
points d'industrie dans le PIB de 600050
alors que vous en avez perdu 10 en 30
ans la vérité et qu'il n'est pas
possible de rendre durablement
la vérité faire collègue et qu'il est
impossible du rendre de rendre
durablement du pouvoir d'achat aux
Français de réindustrialiser massivement
notre pays notre continent d'assurer une
vraie transition écologique sans à
redéploiement massif de la filière
nucléaire en France et en Europe il est
absolument intolérable que votre texte
acte des délais surréalistes de 15 ans
pour construire un réacteur alors que
nos concurrents chinois russes et
coréens libres des centrales entre 6 et
8 ans il est déplorable que vous ayez
refusé tous nos amendements de bon sens
pour ouvrir festenheim en le
transformant en la transformant en
démonstrateur pour prouver que nous
pouvons tirer les réacteurs à 60 voire à
80 ans aussi déplorable de refuser
systématiquement d'envisager
sérieusement le déploiement de la
cogénération nucléaire technologies
sérieuse au potentiel considérable
refuser aussi tous nos plans pour
relancer l'innovation des différents
réacteurs de 4e génération refuser
toutes nos propositions pour relancer
même en Europe heure atome bref nous
lancerons nous voterons pardon ce texte
un cri d'alarme aux Français aujourd'hui
la filière nucléaire n'est pas relancée
et vous ne la relancerez pas sur ce
sujet comme tant d'autres les Français
verront que votre pâle copie dégainera
jamais l'original confiance de Marine Le
Pen dans le génie nucléaire
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur aymeric Caron
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues faire le choix de
l'énergie atomique c'est faire le choix
de l'arrogance et de l'inconscient
arrogance de ce penser à la hauteur
d'une démesure technique dont les effets
mal maîtrisés potentiellement
dévastateurs dominent homo faber et
démente son caractère sapiens
ce qu'une centrale ou une bombe
nucléaire nous rappelle c'est ce que
Gunter unders appelle le décalage
prométhéen c'est-à-dire pour reprendre
ses mots le fait que l'homme est plus
petit que lui-même inférieur à sa tâche
car l'homme qui s’angoisse reste loin
derrière l'homme qui produit en clair
le nucléaire civile et militaire puisque
les deux sont liés doit nous angoisser
parce qu'il représente l'une des
expressions barbares du génie humain la
possibilité d'apocalypse créée par
nous-mêmes mais chers collègues
acceptez-vous d'être angoissé comme le
commande la raison et la fonction que
vous occupez je crois que
malheureusement beaucoup ici préfèrent
l'inconscience à l'angoisse inconscience
ce refus de considérer les alertes du
pire qui steam slimael Island
Saint-Laurent-des-Eaux tchernobyl
Fukushima à propos de Tchernobyl il faut
rappeler que 600 000 liquidateurs ont
été mobilisés pour gérer les
conséquences de la catastrophe plus de 8
millions de personnes ont été exposés
aux radiations Biélorussie en Ukraine et
en Russie aujourd'hui un million de
personnes vivent encore dans des zones
contaminées des milliers de kilomètres
carrés sont un propre à la vie humaine
personne ne pourra vivre autour de la
centrale pendant encore plus de 20 000
ans le nombre de talent de victimes et
toujours impossible à connaître avec
précision mais les estimations
indépendantes comptabilisent sur le long
terme des dizaines voire des centaines
de milliers de morts
en France officiellement Tchernobyl n'a
eu aucune conséquence à l'époque les
autorités ont même dit circuler il y a
rien à voir le nuage radioactif s'est
arrêté aux frontières c'était un
mensonge bien sûr mais le nucléaire a
besoin du mensonge pour être accepté
madame la ministre madame la ministre
madame la ministre c'est à vous que je
m'adresse
vous avez eu recours au mensonge pour
imposer aujourd'hui la relance nucléaire
à cette assemblée et à l'opinion
française quel mensonge le nucléaire
serait une énergie non polluante c'est
faux les centrales produisent des
déchets radioactifs qui salissent nos
sols et qui mettent en péril notre santé
pour des centaines ou pour des milliers
d'années des déchets dont on ne sait
absolument pas quoi faire à part les
enterrés c'est ça c'est ça les limites
du génie humain le nucléaire nous
garantirait madame la ministre est
toujours à vous que je m'adresse nous
garantirait la souveraineté énergétique
c'est faux la France doit importer
l’uranium nécessaire au fonctionnement
des centrales le choix allemand de
sortir du nucléaire serait une
catastrophe parce que compensé par la
relance du charbon c'est faux
l'Allemagne a principalement compensé
l'énergie nucléaire par des énergies
renouvelables et là déjà programmé la
sortie prochaine du charbon
renseignez-vous
la France aurait absolument besoin du
nucléaire pour parvenir à la neutralité
carbone c'est faux
mégawater encore la dame au public des
scénarios qui montrent que nous pouvons
arriver à un mix 100% renouvelable d'ici
2050 les Françaises et les Français
auraient été associés madame la ministre
est toujours à vous que je m'adresse si
vous voulez bien avoir la politesse de
m'écouter à votre choix de relance du
nucléaire
c'est faux il n'y a eu aucun vrai débat
dans le pays et la Commission nationale
du débat public a préféré jeter l'éponge
quand elle a compris que les dés étaient
pipés dès le départ vous mentez encore
sur les coûts du nucléaire
est-ce que vous êtes capable de dire
avec précision combien vont coûter la
prolongation de nos vieux réacteurs et
la construction des nouveaux non bien
sûr vous n'en savez strictement rien le
Pr de Flamanville était annoncé à 3
milliards là encore c'était faux
puisqu'il va coûter au minimum 6 fois
plus est-ce que vous dites aux
Françaises qu'est-ce que vous dites aux
Françaises et offensés sur les risques
liés à la sécurité des centrales
nucléaires et des piscines de stockage
des déchets qu'est-ce que vous dites sur
les conséquences d'une attaque
terroriste ou militaire contre ces
installations vous dites rien vous
préférez le secret défense et l'omerta
pourquoi pendant le temps que nous avons
passé à étudier votre loi à aucun moment
vous n'avez évoqué la centrale de sa
pourritzger en Ukraine où les centrales
voisines au cœur de la guerre alors que
l'AIEA averti sur le risque d'un grave
accident nucléaire en raison des
bombardements est-ce que chez nous en
France le risque de guerre et de
terrorisme n'existe pas pour le croire
il faut être arrogant ou inconscient
madame la ministre madame la ministre
j'ai une question à vous poser à
laquelle j'aimerais que vous répondiez
sans mentir madame la ministre si vous
voulez bien m'écouter
est-ce que vous pouvez promettre aux
Français aux Françaises qu'il y aura pas
dans les années qui viennent d'accidents
majeurs nucléaire en France est-ce que
vous pouvez le garantir madame la
ministre
est-ce que vous pouvez le garantir
non vous ne le pouvez pas chers
collègues avant de voter prenez-en
conscience et un accident grave venez à
toucher un jour un des réacteurs dont
vous auriez soutenu aujourd'hui la
prolongation ou la construction vous
emporteriez la responsabilité et la
culpabilité je vous remercie
alors avant de donner la parole aux deux
derniers orateurs inscrits je vous
rappelle que la Conférence des
Présidents a décidé qu'il serait procédé
à un scrutin public sur le projet de loi
compte tenu du texte de la commission
mixte paritaire et donc je fais d'ores
et déjà annoncer le scrutin dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale et
donc la parole est à monsieur le
président Olivier Marleix
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers mes chers collègues
le groupe des Républicains votre a les
conclusions de cette CMP on se
réjouissant que la plupart de nos
apports à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat étaient maintenus dans ce texte ce
texte il est extrêmement important
puisque il marque une véritable rupture
avec 10 ans pendant lesquels nous avons
tourné le dos au nucléaire dix années où
le président Hollande d'abord le
président Macron ensuite ont résolument
tourné le dôme à cette énergie propre
favorable au climat ce donc un moment
important et les députés les
républicains ont en partage avec les
députés communistes d'être les seuls à
ne jamais avoir abandonné dans ce combat
en faveur du nucléaire quand d'autres
quand d'autres doutaient de cette
énergie qualifiée de dangereuse Madame
Le Pen je vous le rappelle
chacun pourra vérifier ce qui était vos
propos à l'époque
nous regrettons évidemment ces dix
années d'amment la commission d'enquête
présidée par Raphaël schelenberger a
montré ce qu'il y a eu parfois
d'incompétence d'ignorance ou de
sinistre parmi les décideurs publics qui
ont présidé assez chauds malheureusement
et nous n'oublierons pas les
conséquences qui ont eu ces choix sur
toute une filière qui a été affaiblie
conséquence aussi sur le prix de
l'électricité cet hiver conséquence sur
notre perte de souveraineté
ce texte va nous permettre de tourner le
dos donc à 10 années de renoncement mais
malgré tout nos débats ont montré que un
certain nombre de questions se posaient
sur lesquelles le gouvernement n'a pas
totalement convaincu n'a pas fait encore
toute la lumière d'abord comment ne pas
regretter que ce texte précède une
programmation plurie annuelle de
l'énergie qui aurait évidemment dû être
le besoin que l'on sache d'abord de
quelle énergie nous aurons besoin dans
l'avenir et de quelle énergie quelle
énergie nous aurons à produire vous avez
mis la charrue avant les bœufs quels
seront ensuite les acteurs de cette
filière là aussi n'avons pas eu de
réponse quels seront les modes de
financement face à ces besoins
gigantesques pour relancer notre filière
nucléaire madame la ministre j'ai eu
l'occasion à plusieurs reprises de vous
dire mes inquiétudes sur un label
délivré par votre ministère qui
s'appelle le label green fine
ou vous donner des bons points à des
fonds d'investissement qui investissent
dans certains secteurs et vous excluez
vous excluez les gens les fonds qui
investissent dans le secteur du
nucléaire ce que nous rapprochons tous à
la Commission européenne votre
gouvernement continue à le faire à
travers ce label Greenfield c'est
absolument insupportable tout ça
ressemble à un terrible double langage
je vous invite donc à corriger le tir
très rapidement nous aurons donc sur
tous ces sujets là besoin madame la
ministre que le gouvernement revienne
souvent devant l'Assemblée nationale
pour faire le point sur les choix qui
seront ceux de l'exécutif et puis
dernier point on peut pas laisser passer
ce rendez-vous sans rappeler
la situation qui est encore aujourd'hui
celle de nos entreprises par rapport au
coût de l'énergie la situation de
dépendance dans laquelle le renoncement
au nucléaire a plongé la France France
qui était jusqu'en 2019 le premier
exportateur mondial d'électricité s'est
retrouvée par une politique de
sous-investissement et de démobilisation
de la filière nucléaire dans une
situation de dépendance qui fait que
l'hiver dernier nous avons dû importer
20% de notre électricité produite en
Allemagne à base de charbon la
conséquence de cette situation c'est
évidemment que nos entreprises sont été
exposées sont devenus dépendantes de
prix de l'électricité devenue fou sur le
marché européen il y avait ce matin un
article dans Le Parisien qui qui a fait
une enquête auprès de 1400 restaurateurs
sur ces 1400 restaurateurs
85% d'entre eux disaient que la
sauvegarde la pérennité de leur activité
était encore en jeu la restaurateur
place sur l'esplanade des Invalides que
que nous connaissons tous à afficher à
la porte du restaurant une facture
d'électricité en haut de 334 %, c'est ça
Madame le Ministre la situation que nous
avons créé en laissant nos entreprises
exposées au marché au marché mondial au
marche européen de l'électricité sans
avoir le courage d'obtenir une réforme
de ce marché est-ce que nous sommes à
l'abri d'un nouvel épisode de spéculatif
l'hiver prochain nous ne pouvons pas le
garantir vous ne pouvez pas le garantir
donc de grâce madame la ministre l'année
prochaine vous n'aurez plus l'excuse de
ne pas pouvoir anticiper de grâce
anticiper pour éviter une nouvelle crise
pour nos entreprises merci
la parole est maintenant à Madame Louise
Morel
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de commission
madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés il est des moments
dans la vie politique d'un pays où des
choix marqueront durablement l'histoire
pour les décennies à venir aujourd'hui
est un de ces jours le projet de loi qui
nous est présenté marque le début de la
reconquête de notre souveraineté
énergétique ce texte est le premier
jalon d'un chantier industriel qui
s'étalera sur plus d'un siècle et qui
doit conduire à atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 mesdames et messieurs
les députés rappelons-nous que la France
s'est engagée avec l'accord de Paris a
limité l'augmentation de la température
moyenne de la planète en dessous de 2
degrés par rapport au niveau
pré-industriel nous devons tenir cet
engagement tant pour le bien de notre
planète que pour le bien des espèces
qu'il a peuple et il n'y a pas de
formule magique pour cela
en accélérant les procédures liées à la
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaires cette loi permet de
matérialiser concrètement l'objectif de
décarbonation de notre mix énergétique
permettez-moi de préciser que le groupe
démocrate a bien entendu conscience des
difficultés et des interrogations
légitimes que pose le développement de
l'énergie nucléaire toutefois face aux
projections qui montrent une
augmentation de la consommation
d'énergie dans les années à venir face
aux différents scénarios proposés par
RTE qui démontre clairement que les
scénarios composés exclusivement
d'énergie renouvelables présentes bien
trop d'incertitudes quant à leur réel
achèvement il est de notre devoir de
trouver une solution pragmatique et
cette solution c'est le développement de
l'énergie nucléaire de manière raisonnée
encadrée et reposant sur une filière
d'excellence française qui a su faire
ses preuves au cours du temps
qui plus est la parfaite au nucléaire
dans notre mix énergétique a pour
corollaire la réduction de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles et
c'est là notre des réel défi de mettre
fin à l'usage des énergies fossiles le
texte qui nous est présenté aujourd'hui
issu de la commission mixte paritaire et
telle qu'il a été voté mardi dernier par
le Sénat actualise la planification
énergétique simplifie les procédures
administratives relatives à la
construction des nouveaux réacteurs EPR
2 tout en prolongeant la durée de vie
des installations nucléaires existantes
s'il vous plaît permet également
d'améliorer la sûreté la sécurité
nucléaire sur ce dernier volet le texte
final exclut toute fusion entre
l'Institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaires et l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire le groupe démocrate sur
ce sujet avec clairement fait part de
son extrême prudence et interrogation
quant à cette proposition le texte
prévoit ainsi dans la continuité de nos
débats que le gouvernement présentera
d'ici 6 mois en rapport évaluant les
besoins prévisionnels humains et
financiers nécessaires aux missions de
l'URSS de l'ASN et du Commissariat à
l'énergie atomique en définitive ce
texte nous donne les moyens de maîtriser
notre empreinte carbone au travers d'une
politique volontariste nous permettant
de respecter nos objectifs climatiques
grâce à ce texte nous simplifions les
procédures en dispensant les projets de
construction de réacteurs d'étapes
administratives multiples sans jamais
renier sur l'aspect sûreté nous
permettons par exemple d'anticiper le
démarrage des travaux qui ne revêtent
aucun caractère sensible dès l'obtention
d'une autorisation environnementale nous
permettons une mise en compatibilité des
documents d'urbanisme par décret ce qui
accélère le développement des
infrastructures nucléaires et nous
remplissons l'objectif de ce texte qui
est que le temps de construction d'un
réacteur se rapproche au maximum du
temps industriel
le groupe démocrate tient un saluer le
travail réalisé dans le développement de
ce texte ambitieux conjoint avec les
sénateurs il est également la continuité
de l'action engagée depuis 2017 par le
gouvernement afin de se doter de tous
les outils pour remplir nos ambitions
climatiques pour conclure chers
collègues l'adoption de ce texte est un
signal fort envoyé à la filière du
nucléaire en France mais également au
monde avec lui nous affirmons notre
volonté de retrouver l'outil et la
culture industrielle nécessaire à la
réussite de grands projets nucléaires
conjointement avec la loi relative à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable ce texte nous
permet de nous diriger vers un modèle de
mix énergétique français pérenne qui
nous permettra d'atteindre nos objectifs
de neutralité carbone en 2050 pour ces
multiples raisons le groupe démocrate
vient votre a bien entendu en faveur de
ce texte et vous invite chers collègues
à faire de même je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la discussion générale et close et donc
je mets aux voiles projet de loi tel
qu'il est
issu de la commission mixte paritaire je
vous prie de bien vouloir regagner vos
places
[Musique]
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
donc votant 538 exprimés 499 majorité
250 pour
399 contre 100 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
je suspends la séance pour 2 minutes